واخيرا يمسك هذا الصغير بيد جدته بعد طول
انتظار لم يبقى لدى اليكس و جدته تتيانا
التي تعيش في الجزء الخاضع لسيطره
اوكرانيا من مقاطعه خيرسون بعد سجن والدته
في
روسيا هي واحده من قصص كثيره لعائلات
فرقتها الحرب في
اوكرانيا مشكله انسانيه سارعت قطر للتوسط
فيها بين طرفي النز
بهدف لم شمل الاطفال وعائلاتهم لدواع
انسانيه في سفاره قطر لدى موسكو بدات
المرحله الاولى من عمليه لم شمل العائلات
الاوكرانيه عمليه وصفتها الخارجيه القطريه
في بيان لها بانها بدايه مهمه نحو لم شمل
بقيه الاطفال المتاثرين بالحرب وتعكس
موثوقيه قطر دوليا لدى مختلف الاطراف
والتزام الدائمه بتعزيز السلام والامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه والعالم واستعدادها
للقيام بدور بناء وفاعل في مختلف الازمات
والصراعات كما عبر البيان عن تقدير الدوحه
لاوكرانيا وروسيا لتعاونهما والتزامهما
بضمان سلامه وامن
الاطفال وتتضمن المرحله الاولى تسليم خمسه
اطفال وقصر الى ذويهم
بمساهمته من قبل السفاره القطريه في موسكو
دور قطر لا يقدر بثمن فبالنسبه لنا من
المهم وجود طرف ثالث محايد فالغرب ينقل
الاخبار بطريقته ولا يعترف بان روسيا تقوم
بتسليم الاطفال ولا تضع اي عقبات امام ذلك
لذا فان قطر هي بمثابه الشاهد حيث تقوم في
هذه الحاله السفاره القطريه بمراقبه عمليه
اعداد الوثائق وكيفيه استقبالنا لذوي
الاطفال واقربائهم ونقلهم لاحقا عبر الممر
الانساني وبرزت هذه المشكله الانسانيه مع
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث اصدرت
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال في
حق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ومفاوضات
لحقوق الطفل ماري الفوفا بيلوفا امر رفضته
القياده الروسيه واعتبرته مسيسا لا يملك
قوه قانونيه لعدم اعتراف موسكو بهذه
المحكمه هي خطوه تاتي في اطار جهود
وسياسات تبنتها دوله قطر للوساطه في تسويه
النزاعات وفي هذا السياق اعربت الخارجيه
القطريه عن املها ان ينعكس هذا النجاح على
وساطات اخرى تقوم بها حاليا ران دريدي
الجزيره
موسكو